[Music]
this morning in our Saturday session the
National the widely renowned band just
released their seventh album yesterday
and many critics are calling it their
best yet and one of the best albums of
the year in a moment they'll perform for
you but first we spoke with a group that
they're a home base in Hudson New York
when did you start working on this so I
moved up here three years ago when
guitarist Aaron Dessner bought an 18th
century farmhouse in the Hudson Valley
of New York for his family he also saw
it as an oasis for his band the national
and the idea was like if we can get this
done in six months then the band can
make a record here an old barn was
rebuilt into their new studio and this
is the album cover but in the long palm
studio the National recorded sleep well
Beast the latest album from brothers
Aaron and Bryce Dessner
Brian and Scott Devendorf and lead
singer Matt Berninger
I think the kitchen where all the
ingredients got like thrown into the pot
and cooked and chopped up we spent more
time in the same room then we have since
probably the beginning of the band the
National formed in 1999 five cincinnati
kids who came together in brooklyn threw
seven albums
they've become one of Indy Rock's most
successful bands but in the four years
since their last record as their
families have grown they've scattered
far and wide
you guys all live in different places
now California correct Long Island New
York
Paris France
and I live here except when I live in
Copenhagen Denmark yeah you all have
kids you all live in different places
but you're all still connected I feel
like we're more connected now just do
like the times that we have together
kind of more special and specialized
like we're here to do a thing but we're
also here to like regrouped what did you
want to do in here well so the idea was
their new studio built from the wood of
the old barn looks out on the Long Pond
I guess it's like a headquarters or a
clubhouse or you know and but people
feel like they're on vacation kind of
yes it's the perfect environment no why
is it the perfect environment I've never
been in a place that's nice in this
tranquil honestly been swimming in that
pond and there's like red-winged
blackbirds landing in the cattails it's
kind of ridiculous and it's here the
national now come to rediscover
themselves it can be exciting but also
frightening because you don't know he
actually feel like maybe you'll never
write a good song again or something or
maybe the band will just sort of
disintegrate I think our biggest fear as
a band is like repeating ourselves and
kind of this idea of like a success semi
successful rock band that falls in love
with its own image or its own shadow and
like so we're kind of challenging that
all the time and sort of nothing sacred